now thanks for joining us at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm david charns in
for brian tonight a veteran's housing
community asking for your help to find
one of their own we're talking about
patty palowski she went missing from her
home at hebron downtown about a week ago
and those who know her are worried that
something is seriously wrong sasha
loftis joining us live near las vegas
boulevard in charleston with more sasha
denise and david those living here at
hebron formerly share village say they
are just looking for their family member
they hope someone out in the community
has the answers to help bring her home
we need her to come back a downtown
community is calling for help as they
search for one of their own we just hope
that she's okay
she
would never leave the dog patty pawalski
vanished from her home last friday night
here at hebron formerly share village on
las vegas boulevard near charleston i
think she rescued her property manager
ashley carr says neighbors first figured
something was wrong when her beloved dog
was found deserted early saturday
morning bella was found in the parking
lot with no leash no collar no jacket
just running loose carr says something
like this is completely out of character
for patty so they've been searching for
answers ever since
everybody here misses her
we went out and looked we've looked
everywhere so far they're at a loss so
they hope their efforts to spread the
word will encourage anyone with
information to come forward we've run
and dropped off missing persons flyers
all down las vegas boulevard we have
several residents taking them with them
and help them reunite with this family
member they miss so much
patty we just want you to come home and
we want to make sure you're safe
patty is described as five foot five
around 160 pounds with brown hair and
green eyes if you have any information
that could lead to where she is you are
asked to call the metro police missing
persons unit at 702-828-2900
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now